welcome back to CBS this morning
Michigan's republican-led legislature
has voted to sue the state's Democratic
governor to stop her extending the
coronavirus state of emergency they're
hundreds of protestors some of them with
guns gathered at the State Capitol
yesterday demanding an end to emergency
restrictions only six states have
reported more cases than Michigan but
fewer than 2% of its people have been
tested for the virus in our series on
the state of coronavirus testing
Adriana Diaz shows how Michigan is
trying to improve a system that has
failed some of its people this is like
having a heart Kayla Carruthers mother
Deborah Gatewood worked at Beaumont
Hospital outside Detroit drawing blood
for 31 years but when she came down with
the fever last month her daughter says
that same hospital denied her a Cova
test more than once
how many times did she try to get tested
four times and every time what happened
she got sent home each time she lost
faith in the whole health care system so
your mom a health care worker lost faith
in the health care system beaumont
health told CBS news we're doing
everything we can to evaluate triage and
care for patients based on the
information we know at the time we
grieve the loss of any patient helping
Michigan families Michigan Governor
Gretchen Whitmer has since expanded
testing criteria to include milder
symptoms and all essential workers we
spoke to one of your constituents who
lost her mother to koban 19 being turned
away from a testing center four times
did you expand that criteria too late I
think that's the saddest reality of a
country that was under prepared for
global pandemic the fact that we've
never had enough tests but the federal
government didn't prepare contributes to
the fact that we had to ration tests at
the front end of this pandemic and I
recognize that lives were lost testing
has doubled in recent weeks but
shortages of swabs and chemicals
Ellucian are still an issue the CDC
guidelines are that we should be testing
between 1 to 2 percent of our population
over the course of a week in order to
have some confidence that it's safe to
reopen and it's gonna be a little while
before we get there the governor's goal
is to test at least 14,000 people a day
right now they're doing roughly half
that the epicenter is the Detroit area
which accounts for more than 70 percent
of the state's cases and
disproportionately people of color their
walk of testing has been set up to reach
residents without cars by executive
order
the governor has shut down most of the
economy drawing ire from a small but
vocal minority some think she's gone too
far
like Sheriff Ted Jindal of rural Benzi
County keep in mind we're on executive
order number 60 I've detect you feel a
certain way about that well yeah because
there's just one right after the other
so one size fits all kind of approach I
can use my County example we have zero
deaths
let's give us a chance to get out go
back to work put food on the table for
our families but the governor says
testing above all else will help
determine when to fully reopen some
people will think we should move faster
I'm going to listen to the public health
experts and I'm going to work with the
business side of the equation to make
sure that we've got the protocols to
keep people safe when it is safe to
start to reengage
the governor says she may further open
the economy region by region if the data
shows it safe now putting Michigan back
to work won't make up for the roughly 3
billion dollars a state estimates it'll
lose because of the pandemic